- I ask your punk ass if you
went over there to buy some
motherfucking dope.
I wasn't standing out here for my health.
So you disregarded the
concern of me and my friends
out here.
So I want to ask you again man,
do you think I'm fucking
joking when I called your
ass over here?
What's in your pocket? Set that shit down.
I'm not robbing you yet, but
what you gonna do is you gonna
split what you got right now just to be
able to walk on away from me.
Now if you think I'm
fucking kidding, what it
feel like to have a bullet in your belly?
Cause it's gonna put you on the ground
and one doesn't put you
on the ground I think
you might need to go for a double up.
Now what you think?
So why you wanna do that?
He say he wanna split
the stuff that he got.
Well split it and I'ma let
you walk your motherfucking
ass on down the street.
But the next time you bring
your silly ass down here
you better god damn acknowledge
the people out here.
Cause we ain't out here for
our health everybody's out--
Until I burn you, you ain't
got no right to god damn
disregard me out here.
This motherfucker ain't no better then me
he's the same as me.
So split that down and you
go on about your business
I'll see you, you have a
good day all right bud.
All right, ill holla at you,
so I try and talk to people,
I try and talk to them
good man, I don't just automatically take
nothing from them unless
its supposed to be took.
If I ask you a question, I say,
"dog you here to buy some dope?"
You say, "Yeah."
I say, "Well I got it."
You say, "Well I don't
want it from you man,"
"you know I don't know what you got."
I got the same shit he got,
fuck you mean what I got?
So when you pull a gun
out and then you say,
"Okay, you don't wanna believe me then."
You wanna holla at my
buddy charlie right here?
He'll talk to you though, I
can't talk to you like he can,
But he can get some
motherfucking response-
I bet you he'll get a positive
response, what you think?
You know, so we going
to start off new today.
What's your name?
They call me Larry, Big Larry.
This is my buddy charlie, he only come out
when he asks to go meet people.
So today he wanted to meet you.
I didn't think you wanted
to meet him though,
what you think?
Split that money man.
You know what, How much is that?
Just give me all that,
I'm gonna give you some-
don't make me trip out
man, give me all of it,
and we gonna split some of it to
make sure you got
something in your pocket.
Now how much is this, 2 hundred something?
Okay here goes 20 for you, now go on.
Yeah I'm gonna take it all,
I gave you 20 didn't I?
So you can get your ass home,
get you something to eat,
and don't come down here
to buy no drugs no more
Okay?
Go home, go on man!
All right, now the reason
you make people cooperate
like that is because they
already in violation buying dope.
See, I went to jail for
robbing a dope house, not
for robbing the citizens, Not
the people in this country.
I robbed a drug house, and
I tried to straighten it out
with the people that
were at the drug house.
I got a couple of bumps back here.
You know, You never
know what it feels like
when a man takes your gun, and
I did have that done to me.
One of my partners he say,
"SB You robbed one of them
spots, did you though?"
I didn't really know if I could trust him,
to tell him the truth.
He said, 'Man I'm just trying
to look out, you my boy man."
"I don't want nothing to happen to you."
"Did you rob the spot?"
I said, "Yeah I robbed it."
I mean but shit, it wasn't me by myself,
but I accept my own.
I say, "Yeah I robbed it"
He said, "Look they around
there slipping right now."
Take the AK, Told me to take an AK-47.
Go around there, and
give it to them niggas
right now while they're
posted early in the morning.
I was like, "Man, I really
didn't want it to go this far,"
"damn, you want me to take
the chopper over there man?"
"Like that?"
He said, "Man they talking
about getting you though SB"
I was like, "Man, I'm just
gonna grab the nine dog,"
"I got a nine right here in the house."
So I took the nine, made
sure the clip was loaded,
made sure it had 16 in it,
then one in the chamber.
17 is really hard to squeeze.
I went around there, I rode my bike.
I parked the bike around the corner
on the side of the building,
and went up in the house.
I got two T-shirts on,
because I don't want you
to see the reflection of the gun.
I walked in the house I
was like, "Was sup dog."
And they was like, "Here
this nigga go right here"
I was like, "Nigga what's up nigga?"
Nigga you robbed the spot nigga.
I said, Nigga I ain't rob no spot nigga,
fuck you talking about.
Nigga we seen you, nigga you had some
woopty woop kinda shoes.
I said, "Nigga I aint got no boots nigga,"
"I don't own no boots homeboy,
you got me fucked up homeboy"
He said, "Nigga you
robbed the spot nigga,"
"I know your voice and shit"
I said, "Nigga how the
fuck you gonna say,"
"you know my voice nigga, I
didn't rob the spot nigga."
He said, "Yes B look man
I was just saying dog,"
"just slide us back the money
man, you can keep the dope"
you know whatever money
you got out of here
let's just get that.
I said, "Homie I don't got nothing man."
You know, that's on everything dog.
I didn't rob the spot homie.
So while I was talking to him,
this lil' nigga go out the back door.
I didn't know what was
going on, he leave though.
They had the opportunity to knock me down,
right then and there.
Because when this nigga leave,
I'm up here still trying
to clear it up with you,
that it aint me dog.
I'm swearing on everything,
swearing on my homies,
on my dead homies, you know?
Trying to convince you
that I didn't do this dog.
When the nigga come back,
The little nigga that
came back, he come in-
(Gun hits the floor)
Whoa, Excuse me.
My bad, I don't want nothing to happen.
Ain't nothing in this clip so
we all right, we all right.
Anyway, when this nigga
come in he passed him a gun,
I don't know them.
He call him in the kitchen,
I'm thinking they finna chop up some dope
or something trying to make up for
the loss they just took.
He called him into the kitchen.
when I see him in the kitchen,
he put the gun in his pocket Like this.
And he got it hanging like this.
and the the pants were sagging,
he don't know I got this gun like this,
right here.
While I'm trying to square it off,
when I see the gun I'm like, "Whoa."
So the little nigga is who gave him a gun,
but the little nigga got a little 25.
He got a little 25 in his
hand, big about like this.
And I'm looking at it, He was like,
"We sent this nigga to jack you nigga,"
"nigga you need to handle your business."
So in the hood, when a
person tells you that,
he's telling him to shoot
me right now, whatever.
Prove to us that you loyal to us,
and that you gon' knock this
nigga down for robbing you.
If he die, he die.
If he live, okay he'll
know not to rob you again.
That's how it goes, you
gotta accept whatever
come to you in the hood
dog, and I aint bullshitn'.
And this nigga, when I seen
that gun, oh man I mean,
everything that I
thought was strong in me,
ran with the fear.
I was scared as a muhfucka man,
this nigga got a big ass gun right here.
And I'm like, "Goddamn."
I'm really now trying
to plead to this nigga
that I didn't rob you dog,
I'm telling you I didn't man.
But I don't wanna tell on this other nigga
that was with me.
I could just say, "Man, this the nigga,"
"who really robbed you."
But I gotta remain strong on this one.
You know, because I still
got something out of it.
I got a portion of the dope,
I got a portion of the money,
so I had to say-you know
I had to be strong and keep my lips quiet.
And take it to the grave,
'cause that's where I'm gonna go today.
This morning, 'cause
it was in the morning.
About maybe 10 o'clock.
Anyways so while we in the house
yelling at one another, the
nigga in the living room,
on the couch 'cause there was
three niggas in the house.
The nigga on the couch say,
"Man you niggas need
to take that outside!"
So he telling him, "Once
you get him outside,"
"you good to bust on him."
So when he do that, I'm like, "Oh."
He's like, "Man let's Roll"
I'm like, "Nigga you roll first,"
"nigga come on nigga y'all go first."
Nigga I aint finna go
in front of you niggas
to shoot me in the back, you know.
So when they roll first,
I reach up under my waist,
I grab the gun.
as soon as I get outside nigga, I said,
"Nigga don't grab the gun dog,"
"don't make me kill you homie."
"I'm telling you dog,
do not grab that gun"
And then the other homie
that just walked up,
he like man don't shoot,
don't grab the gun nigga
SB gon' kill you."
I gotta shoot you dog if
you grab that gun dog.
If you tend to reach for it nigga,
ima bust you right now nigga.
So when I go like this, he
said, "I aint gon' grab it!"
All right then, The other
little dude that had a gun,
I was finna bust on him though.
He broke, he got a gun,
What you want it for nigga?
That nigga ran, When he took off,
I caught his little ass legs though.
Anyways, let me finish this out.
Anyways, Once he said
what he said, I said,
"Nigga ima spare you nigga."
Somebody said, "Why didn't
you take the gun from him?"
Nigga I'm not over here
to take a gun nigga,
I'm over here to save my life.
I told that nigga,
"Look, you go that way,"
"and ima go this way."
If you turn back around nigga,
that means you ready to fall.
Now get nigga, Right now, go nigga!
Skip nigga, that nigga
skipped his ass on around.
I ran that way, my bike
on the side of the wall.
I jumped on my bike, I'm gone.
I run across the police,
we got a lot of police
raiding that stuff at the time.
I'm like, "Whoa, I'm glad."
'Cause if the shooting would've went on,
they would've caught me running
somewhere along the line.
I would've been dead then.
But I'm glad and I thank God
that it didn't happen that way.
I shot onto the house,
when I got into the house,
I told my brother, "Look baby, It's on."
"them niggas is out for
me, so whatever you do,
you gotta stay close to the house,
and let me know where you
going and shit like that.
'Cause I don't want them to
catch you slippin' either.
You know, make sure you let me know.
Other than that, Don't leave this house.
At that time my girl, she was pregnant.
So I didn't wanna disregard
the safety for her, you know.
I didn't have enough
money to move her nowhere.
So she aint goin so she can
stay her ass right in this
house, and that's what we gon do.
And I just said, "Forget it."
I bought me another gun, so I kept two.
And the niggas that see
me, I be standing outside.
They see me, They pass by in the car.
They see me, I said, "I wish yall asses"
"would stop right there."
Acting like you wanna
get out the muhfucka.
Ill serve you niggas good nigga.
Aint no dope and aint no money
coming back, its over now.
I know how people, you never think that
family would cross you up,
my family crossed me up.
He said, "SB look, these
niggas is scared of you dog."
"They already know what you bout SB."
"Go around there and talk to them niggas,"
"man they aint trippin'
over the little stuff,"
"you took from em."
I said, "Nigga, I don't really
wanna talk to them niggas."
I don't need to talk to them, for what?
He said, "Just to let them know that,"
"you know that you sayin'
everything is cool."
I said, "dog did they send you over here"
"to get at me like this?"
He like, "No SB, I'm just sayin' dog."
"You've been knowing them niggas,"
"since they was lil' kids and stuff."
I said, "Dog, I don't give
a fuck about that though."
"You come over here soft
trying to making me feel"
"like I owe them niggas an
explanation or something, nigga."
Bruh Long, look here
man, it ain't like that.
Son of a bitch set me up dog.
He said, man you ain't
even gotta walk around,
you going around and letting
them niggas see the gun and stuff.
You letting them niggas
know it's still on SB.
I said, "You right."
So I'm swallowing some of
this 'cause this my family.
You know this my sister's husband,
you know, My nephews daddy.
So I'm believing this bitch ass nigga,
I'm like, "You right,
You right, You right."
So You think I should
just go holla at them?
Man they've been asking me about you SB,
trying to make truce with you and shit.
They already know you a gangster dog.
I said, "you know what,
you could be right."
I said, "yeah well I'm strapped,"
"I aint worried about them niggas."
He said, "Man you go
and holla at them SB."
All right, so I go over there,
I see them in a alleyway.
I'm like, "Was sup dog?"
Oh what's up nigga, like what's happening.
When they say that, it made me withdrawal,
like what's up, what's
happening, shit like that.
So Niggas like, as I'm coming closer,
Nigga like, "Where my shit at nigga!?"
My brother in law didn't tell me this.
So I went to reach for the gun,
before I could get the gun
fully in my hand, he grabbed it.
So we strugglin now,
I'm up here struggling,
with the nigga with the
gun, with my gun, Right?
The other nigga come from
the side of the building,
hit me in the head with a board.
I still got the knot right back here.
He hit me in the head with the board,
but I know, oh man, I'm like kinda
dizzy a little bit but
I'm tryna hold this nigga,
cause he tryna grab the gun from me.
I know that the gun in my hand,
I'm tryna hit the pin
to knock the clip out,
Cause I got one in the chamber.
But if I drop the clip, its
only one in the chamber.
I'm hoping that I can kinda like
discharge the gun or something, you know?
While I'm tryna get this clip out,
'cause me and him wrastling with it.
I'm dizzy though, from that nigga
hittin' me in the head with the board.
When he take another swing, he missed me.
And when he missed me, me and this nigga.
I go back, I fall in the bushes.
I'm tryna hold the gun
but the nigga somehow
some kinda way got the best of the gun,
he got the stronger part of
the wrastlin where the gun,
I had to let it go dog.
I fell in the bushes, 'cause
like I said the board hit me.
I'm bleeding Like this, its running down,
I still got the bump right
here at the back of my ear.
I'm bleedin down right, so
when I get up out the bushes,
he aint knowing there's
one in the chamber.
He go back for the clip.
I'm tryna zig-zag away,
to make it over where
my lil brother stay at.
I guess he got the clip, he
picked it up, start bustin'.
Boom, Boom, Boom, Boom, Boom!
I'm zig-zaggin' like this
tryna get to my brother house.
When I get to the back porch
I'm just like sittin' there.
I see the blood coming
down and I'm like, "Damn,'
I don't know where I'm hit at.
So I hit the back door,
I hit the screen door.
My little brother come to the back door,
he like, "What's up SB?"
I'm like, "Check it out dog."
I just got into it with
baby and lamant over there.
Nigga got my gun though dog.
He said, "that who was shootin'?"
yeah he got my gun, he
started bustin at me with it.
"I said, "I don't know
if I'm shot or not."
I don't feel like I'm hit, but
I know some blood comin down.
He said, "SB you bleedin
right there, lemme see."
I said, "The nigga lamant
he hit me in the head,"
"he hit me in the back with the board."
Aw Shit I feel bad,
I just wanna make sure I aint shot dog,
Help me up.
I got up, my brother we did a scan check,
on my body and shit.
He said, "You look like you straight SB."
I'm like, "Look,"
"I need the uzi dog, give
me that nine uzi up there."
Now we got a uzi, you don't even feel,
this part of the gun its so hollow.
Its like a fiberglass,
like, its real light.
Only thing that's heavy on it is the clip.
Got a clip this long, shoots 40 times.
I put that in, and then you
gotta always gotta make sure
when you draw the pin
back, that it connects,
'cause that's how people
get em when they jam.
When they tryna bust it
and it starts jammin'.
'cause the pin its got to
eject every time a shell come.
Every time you bust a
shell, you got the semi,
automatic, and so on, you know,
you put it on what you want it on.
And at this time I didn't know all that.
So I just had it on regular,
Once you throw the clip
in, make sure it pops in.
And then you draw the bullet back.
And it hits the chamber.
I went over there, I'm
looking for these niggas.
I told my boy, "What's happening?"
He said, "Yeah SB, I got you dog"
So my other homie Wing, he
said he catch you right.
He said SB, I got the nigga, he said,
"niggas is standing in
front of the front porch."
And I asked him about
the goods, and so on.
Nigga didn't say nothing
so I pulled out both nines,
and started bustin, the other one jammed.
Started bustin this one at him,
and the nigga jumped in the bushes.
Started yelling at his
momma and stuff like that.
But nigga I just kept lettin off
the bullets till all the shells was out.
Then I broke, he went to the hospital.
He lived through it though,
but its just a point that,
I told my relative that the
nigga that did me like that,
so we was looking for em.
I didn't catch him when
I went back over there.
It was like a ghost town, you know.
So he thinkin like, "Shit I got SB's gun."
That's like a payment of ours.
So they kept lying around,
letting me know that you got my gun.
You know, Ill come get you though nigga.
I just gotta get you at the right time.
'cause I don't want no slip ups,
and I don't want you to
think you got away with that.
My brother in law, his fake
ass, he twisted me up on it.
I told that nigga I said,
"Why you send me over there like that?"
Saw my lil brother, he knocked
the brother-in-law out.
A lot of times you gotta
really remember, that
I learned how to be
strong on my on because
my bigger brother they were in jail,
and I had to fight for myself,
and I had to do what I had to do.
And I know that, a lot of times when you
deal with niggas that they call thugs,
or hoodlums, gangsters, whatever.
You gotta have some protection with you.
And your hands aint always the protection.
The police aint gon always
be able to save you.
So sometimes you have to
find security for yourself.
To do what you gotta do, I
know its bad when you say that.
Shootin' a person or killin' a person.
I aint ready to go yet,
but if he wanna go early,
Ill send him on up there to God.
And they can get acquainted
a lot more sooner.
That's how I look at it,
but I aint ready to go.
But that's how you gotta look,
at these jackasses down here dog.
Some of em, they play hard ball,
and you gotta prepare
yourself to play hardball too.
They don't give a fuck who
you is or where you come from.
The fuck you mean, 'cause I'm
a white guy, or I'm a Mexican.
They don't give a fuck about that,
bullets don't come with names.
When the fuck you started pickin out-
oh this charlie you
aint gon shoot charlie.
Or Kevin or this Mark, Mark
gon get his ass shot too.
You know, just straight up being real.
I mean you really gotta
use your strong side.
Gotta get your weak side,
and your strong side.
When we was growing up,
whatever side you used the most,
Try using the other side,
'cause you still got
that good side then.
Remember when you play basketball,
and you fight, Write.
Now try and rotate that hand over here.
This avoids all the stress, depression,
strokes and stuff man.
'Cause I'm left handed,
brother you know it or not.
I done knocked a lot of niggas
out with this left hand.
I done whooped a lot of niggas asses.
I could tell you someone
to tussle that I done had,
boy you'd be scared to
say you'd even been there.
That's how bad its been
for me, But I've been
surrounded, in certain situations,
Where I had to use a gun,
in order to save my own ass.
And I never tell people about
a lot of things I did because,
I don't want it to go back
and open up a book, and say,
"Oh here's this guy right here.
Ima take it to the grave, so if you missed
the part you were
supposed to caught on to,
that's on you.
What you really try to stroke on,
the peoples that I dealt
with as far as robbin,
I robbed a drug house,
I went to jail, they gave me 18 years,
I did the whole damn 18.
You really gonna really like,
but you really don't wanna
show it to everybody,
you might get to show it to some people,
but not to everybody.
These are some real life rod line cuts.
You hit a muhfucka in the mouth with this,
or in the face with this you
gon break everything with it.
(metal hits the floor)
You gon' tear his ass up.
I got a nice gun in here you'd like.
Oh, yes sir, later though I have to,
break him down and put him together.
Its a nice gun we aint seen no
AR-15's and stuff like that.